well the Muslim population of the West
is rising very quickly and that has
implications for social cohesion or
national security but it's also
influencing fashion Macy's has announced
a new line of fashionable Islamic guard
modest Islamic Guard targeted at Muslims
that is the latest retailer to join that
trend both Nike and American Eagle
already have lines like that what does
it mean the National Organization for
Women in New York City and she joins us
tonight so hey thanks for coming on I'm
happy to be here so um this announcement
was cheered by feminists and it got me
thinking do you think that Islam is a
feminist religion well what I think is
that religion in every form throughout
history has oppressed women in many ways
and Islam isn't any different
I think what's striking to me about this
new line of Macy's is that Muslim women
in the United States have forty four
billion dollars in buying power that's
pretty that's pretty spectacular well
that's great I mean I'm all for buying
power though I but I want to get back to
the clothing and its implications I mean
the point of Islamic clothing is to
promote modesty among women for a bunch
of different reasons it's in the Quran
it's it's of course a central part of
Islamic culture so are you for that do
you think women should be coerced to
dress to dress modestly is that a
feminist goal I think what a feminist
goal is is for women to be in control of
their lives and their destinies and to
have choices so whether a woman wants to
wear a hijab or she doesn't is really
not the point I think what's really
interesting what we've been seeing you
wait wait wait wait what do you mean
this I'm confused what it's not the
point so if I say as Islamic countries
do you don't you don't have a choice you
have towards a job because you need to
be you need to be modest and if you're
not you could get raped and if you do
it's your fault and you have to avert
your gaze from men and not touch non
male nun relatives who are men is that
okay
which I was referring to the United
States but you know what's really
interesting if you take a look at what's
happening here you have in the United
States when
had never donned a hijab in their entire
life and and marched over to JFK Airport
at the time of the Trump travel ban and
started wearing a hijab because as a
symbol of resistance in protest to that
and at the same time so they're wearing
them as a symbol of empowerment and at
the same time you have right now in Iran
you have women who are bravely getting
up on platforms and ripping off their
hijab because it's completely sure
because it's compulsive touristed right
no and I would agree with you I'm on
their side completely but would you be
if Macy's sold a new line of Chinese
foot binding shoes would those be
empowering too
I think it's a little bit different
because that is that actually would
damage your feet you'd have to probably
go to I don't know I mean just damage
that although all cosmetic procedures
damage the body all of them that's not
really an answer would you be but if
women's if woman said I find that
empowering just as I find it empowering
to wear clothing that millions of Muslim
women are forced to wear because they're
women in order to be modest that's
somehow empowering so I'm wondering what
is there anything that's not it's not
it's not that simple it's not black and
white for some women it is indeed
empowering and for others it is not and
it really is a matter of perspective as
to where you are let's talk about you
what about field general relations that
there in the subway on August days I
feel so bad for American men with their
suits and their ties I feel bad but
probably for other reasons but you just
take it past this idea and I'm I'm
trying to be open-minded because I'm an
open-minded man a modern man but the
idea that a garment that a religion has
forced women to wear for more than a
thousand years because they're women
forcing them to be modest is somehow
empowering for women do you mean do you
think that for example women are asked
to walk behind their husbands or in some
countries are not allowed to drive or
vote on
certain circumstances can that be
empowering and female genital mutilation
be empowering that's common in Islamic
countries I think those are those are
quite extreme examples that you're
trying to compare they're all they're
all features of the same religion and
they're all gender specific so I don't
know I mean I think they're extreme - I
agree with you but I think the job is
extreme but you don't for some reason
and I don't know why you know I said
there are there are women who do find it
empowering but most importantly it's
really not the top issue I don't go to
work every day and think about what
wardrobes women are wearing and what it
represents because I know enough oh
really because I thought that was a huge
part of women's liberation no I'll tell
you what's a big part of women's
liberation is making sure that the Trump
administration does not roll back our
rights to full reproductive an abortion
right I go to work every day to think
about how to close the pay the wage gap
I'm sure you think maybe you care more
about identity politics than women I've
just thrown that out there but if you're
ador Singh his job maybe it's not really
about women as that occurred to you I'm
not endorsing the only thing that I'm
endorsing here today with you and with
all of your viewers is that
discrimination is alive and well for
women in the country in the form of the
hijab for example just to name one no in
the workplace what we need to do is end
sexual harassment in the workplace job -
I would gap and if those women I do that
while wearing a hijab more power to them
and I won their worth in binding - or
FGM whatever it takes Sonya thank you so
much great thank you so much it's been
fun